monsieur le Président de ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre Olivia
Grégoire la filière requin représente
plus de 11 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires 20 000 entreprises et 66000
emplois directs cette filière irrigue
notre territoire elle est présente dans
91% des cantons avec plus d'un million
de chevaux l'équitation c'est aussi 2
millions de pratiquants dont 700 000
licenciés et donc la troisième
fédération olympique et le premier sport
féminin le monde du cheval s'est enfin
plus de 827 millions de recettes
directes pour l'État à travers les paris
hippiques et 295 millions d'euros à
travers la TVA dans la période que nous
traversons beaucoup de Français ont du
mal à boucler leurs fins de mois les
activités qui ne constituent pas un luxe
mais une force économique pour nos
territoires ruraux et la passion d'un
grand nombre de nos compatriotes comme
vous le savez à la suite d'une décision
de justice européenne la filière se bat
depuis plus de 10 ans pour trouver un
taux de TVA conforme à son caractère
agricole et lui permettant d'être
compétitive je rappellerai juste qu'en
Irlande concurrent direct de nos
éleveurs la TVA est à 4,1%. alors que le
Sénat avait voté dans le PLF un
amendement permettant de revenir à un
taux réduit pour la filière et au
lendemain de l'adoption du budget 2023
par le 49-3 la déception est grande le
président de la République avait
pourtant obtenu en 2022 la révision de
la directive TVA pour permettre à la
France de revenir autour réduit
antérieur et c'était engagé à les
appliquer dès que possible ma question
est donc simple madame la ministre quand
et par quel véhicule législatif le
gouvernement donnera la filière équine
un cadre fiscal garantissant sa
pérennité et son développement et le
respect de la parole donnée